rubbish piled up in the streets more
than four decades ago as the winter of
discontent brought the country to its
knees and the labor government with it
strikes closed services and industries
with workers protesting against pay
lagging behind inflation
43 years on and workers are striking
this summer with some of the same
demands
mick berry is all but retired now but he
remembers the winter of discontent and
the waves of industrial action that
followed it
it could be awkward you had a lot of
friends who
argued with you know your fallouts and
things like that
now a volunteer at the keithley bus
museum he's not surprised strikes are on
the cards again standalone is gone in
this country to go look to what it was
the downside is i suppose there's
more people there's more cars it's more
of everything but i don't think wages
are
meeting that in in any way certainly out
of industries it isn't doing
in just over a week's time the rail
system will be shut down according to
the rmt union three days of strikes are
planned for 13 train operators with the
london underground also affected on the
first day
the transport secretary grant shaps says
the government will look at changing the
law so employers can bring in agency
staff although it can't happen in time
for the planned strikes
unions are outraged if you think about
what grand chaps is trying to do with
that legislation is to make industrial
action ineffective now i believe it's a
basic human right to be able to withdraw
your labor you only do it as a last
resort if people can be brought in to
undermine disputes it will lead to
bitterness it will lead to division and
it will lead to these problems getting
worse
meanwhile labor is calling on the
government to listen to workers the way
to resolve this is to get people around
the table but the idea that you can
replace a skilled train signaler with an
agency worker would you feel safe going
on a train knowing that it was an agency
worker rather than a properly skilled
and trained up trained signal i know
that i wouldn't so instead of this
fanning the flames and increasing
tensions the government needs to act
like firefighters rather than arsonists
[Applause]
the government says it wants the unions
and rail industry to work together but
for now the rail strikes are due to
start on the 21st of june
gerard tubbs sky news